Welcome, everybody, to
our lovely, lovely panel
called "Creating
Dance Virtually."
We have some wonderful
student performers
and our dance lecturer for
music and theater arts.
What we're going to do-- we want
to let everybody know that we
are recording the session
so that this can be viewed
asynchronously, so if you
would not like to be on video,
feel free to mute your video
so you're not recorded.
Thank you, thank you, all
panelists for being here.
We're going to go ahead and
start with Faraaz and Ani
and then we're
going to go to Joy,
going to go to Dan.
And then we'll do a question
and answer afterwards,
where we'll ask you two
questions in the chat,
and then we'll go from there.
So let's start with
Faraaz and Ani.
Cool.
Yes, so Ani and I are
going to be talking
about creating dance virtually.
Ani, you want to take it away?
Yeah, sure.
So basically, who are we?
Faraaz was an MEng
student in 6-3 last year,
and I am currently a junior
in 5-7, which is biochemistry.
And we've basically been dancing
since our freshman years.
So we both started off dancing
on Mirchi, and from there
we both ended up moving on and
also dancing on Ridonkulous
and Movementality.
Ridonkulous is the top
left, Movementality
is like the top middle one,
and Mirchi's one in the red.
And this last picture here is--
Faraaz choreographed a dance
for dance troupe, which
is the big dance
program at MIT, and I
was in this dance as well,
along with a lot of our friends.
And basically,
before COVID, here
is just some of
our performances,
just a quick cut of all that.
Yeah, so this is just to
show a relative comparison.
But about a minute.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, ooh ooh ooh, it
ain't my first time.
But baby girl, we can't
pretend this pumping ground,
because tonight will never
end, let me take your down.
Hey--
I really want to take you down.
[MUSIC, ANDERSON.PAAK, "COME
DOWN"]
Can't beat it, can't
beat it, can't beat it,
with a big bat though Can't
see her with this pitch
black Gucci frames on.
Let me get the full scope.
Huh, full screen, HD, let
me take another picture,
let me pull it to the pre--
Whoops, sorry.
Yeah so those were
basically some of the--
some teams that we've been
on in and some performances
that we've been a part of.
And now I guess we'll
get to the point
where we talk about how things
have changed since everything
sort of went online.
We're going to be talking
about a piece that we created
and a showcase that
has been hosted
by Movementality both during--
both basically in
mid-April, and then
also kind of briefly touching
on logistics of dancing,
especially going into
the fall of this year.
So back after we got
kicked off of campus,
after like a couple of weeks,
Ani and I got in a Zoom call
and we're like, hey, you
know things are crazy.
And Ani shaved his head,
which is really crazy.
And I guess this
sort of interaction
inspired us to create
like a concept video
around this, where even though
we're all sort of separate,
we're trying to find ways
to still stay connected.
And so basically
on the right there
is like a screenshot of our Zoom
call where his head is shaved,
and then on the left is kind
of part of the concept video
where that point is
kind of conveyed,
and we'll show a larger but
longer clip of this later.
Some of the challenges that we
faced with this online format
is that over Zoom you know the
audio usually is not synced up,
so trying to choreograph
and collaborate
is pretty difficult. And
I guess the concept we're
trying to do is like a
Zoom call dance video,
and so we had like
a restricted space,
and we had to dance mostly
our hands, which is something
that we're not really used to.
And another question is
how do we showcase this,
because you know usually
Ridonkulous, for example,
hosts a showcase called
Footwork in the spring, which
unfortunately got canceled,
but more on that later.
But some of the
benefits of this format
are that you can have different
takes and put together
different sections, and you
can have interesting screen
formational ideas, have
different backgrounds,
and props, et cetera
to convey your ideas.
So to talk about a little bit
more about the showcase aspect.
So Movementality
decided basically
to host a showcase in mid-April,
kind of around the same time
that Footwork was
supposed to happen
as a way to try to get the
dance community together.
So on the left you can see
there's a Zoom call here,
where everyone's sort of
watching, and here on the right
is the Facebook event.
And some of the challenges
with organizing this
was first deciding
whether we want
to do it live or pre-recorded.
We ended up going
with pre-recorded,
just because it was
logistically easier
and having like a
YouTube playlist.
Then we had to
figure out like how--
who has the best ping and
reliable video playback
and how to deal with
audience response
while the video is being played.
But then some of
the benefits are
that you get attendance
[? admissions ?] all
over the country, seeing
like a lot of people
show up from west
coast and stuff.
And one thing is fun, because
people aren't actually
performing live,
it makes it more
natural to just
immediately discuss pieces
that have been played with
the actual choreographers
and what their idea
was going into it.
And there's also
pretty wide diversity
in pieces that were
actually played.
So now I'm going to show
like a few different clips
from the first MMTV event,
and basically the intro
to the show, some clip with
what Bhangra [? estimated ?]
and part of a longer clip
of our video as well.
I think we're ready to begin
Movementality TV's first ever
digital dance show.
Whooo.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC, JUSTIN BIEBER, "THAT'S
WHAT LOVE IS"] I reach out
to you but my hands
can't hold enough,
enough of your greatness.
You teach me patience.
Like the best of
our worlds collide.
Never understood what it meant.
It meant to submit to love So
beyond what lust is Hey, it's
a blessing that you're in my
life Make me look even better
when we shine we shine together.
Yeah, that's what love is.
Now, that's what love is Don't
nobody else deserve my eyes.
Yeah, so that was
a clip of that,
and we can discuss more in
the questions at the end
if you have any.
But yeah, so now
Ani's going to talk
a little bit about the
logistics, especially
this fall.
Yeah, so since the
fall is all online,
the dance teams basically
have to find a way
to accommodate that.
And what we've realized is
that social media is probably
the most impactful way to do so.
Basically you pub
your upcoming events,
keep track of who your
officers are, and yeah,
basically just get all
your information out there.
And some of the more specific
challenges are like auditions.
So in the past you'd
teach auditions to--
teach them live and basically
watch everyone live as well
and discuss later by recording.
However, that's not
possible anymore.
So that's one of
the main issues.
Another one is like
we discussed earlier,
just choreographing and learning
choreo without synced audio.
So you can't ask questions,
and a lot of those features
are basically gone.
Well, some of the
benefits involve just
being able to combine
different art forms now.
So from video editing to
graphic design, dance and music,
everything just comes
together, and you're
able to find new ways to
express yourself artistically.
And another aspect
is just like maybe
thinking about
dance in a new way.
So instead of focusing on
choreography and teaching,
maybe focus more on
training fundamentals
and improving as dancers
and just growing.
So it's just a time to reflect
on our abilities and our goals
and maybe approach dance
in a different way.
Yep, so that's
basically all we have.
We have links.
I think this slide has
to be sent out anyways,
but we have links
to different teams,
Instagram handles, and as well
as some of the longer versions
of the videos that we play.
But yep, that's it.
All right, thank
you, Ani and Faraaz.
If you guys have
any questions, feel
free to put them in the chat.
We'll talk about it
after all our speakers
have given their presentations.
Joy, come on up.
Hello, can everyone hear me?
Am I good?
OK.
So I'm Joy.
I am in the class of 2022 and
I'm majoring in 6-14 and 18,
with a minor in music.
So I'm really involved in
like a lot of art stuff
on campus besides dance, but
we're here to talk about dance.
So I do not have a presentation
like Ani and Faraaz,
but I was just going to like
kind of show you some videos
and talk about what my dance
team, Asian Dance Team, does.
So I'm the director
of public relations,
so I'm on the exec
team, and I'm also
a traditional choreographer
for the Asian Dance
Team, which is currently the
largest dance team on campus.
We had over 260
members last semester.
It was crazy.
And overall just an overview.
We're focused on
mostly traditional
and contemporary Asian dance,
as well as modern Asian pop,
so that includes K-pop,
J-pop, C-pop, all of that.
And we are not only run at
MIT in the undergraduate
and graduate
communities, but we also
have friends from Harvard
and from the greater Boston
community who join us for
our showcases every semester.
And I think the thing
that's most unique about ADT
and also, I guess, DT
as part of it, is we're
like very, very beginner
friendly and beginner welcome.
So we seek to kind
of create a space
where beginners or like people
who just got into college
and want to try out dance can
feel like safe and welcome
at MIT, which I think
is really important.
And we also pride
ourselves on being
kind of a social community, so
like creating friendships as
well as just being a dance
group and helping everyone
improve their dancing ability.
This semester, just like with
the virtual format, a breakdown
of what we're doing.
We are doing asynchronous
rehearsals, so are we probably
will have some form of, kind of
synchronous like Zoom workshops
every week.
But otherwise,
all our rehearsals
will be uploaded online,
because so many of our members
are in like a non-US
time zone, which
might make it hard for them to
attend synchronous rehearsals.
In addition, all
of our auditions,
which are happening
this weekend,
are kind of like up
to your own time.
So we're sending out
a YouTube playlist
during the 3-hour
audition time window
of like kind of
a workshop style,
like slow choreo breakdown,
teaching run through.
And they have the 3
hours to kind of work
through those
videos on their own
and send their filmed
videos back to us.
So that's what our
audition is consisting of.
And we're also going to have
like a lot of choreographers
on a Zoom call
with breakout rooms
to kind of help answer
questions and guide new members
or beginners along the way.
So that's kind of
exciting, and I
will be running some
of the audition shifts,
so if you are coming into
auditions I will be there.
Say hi.
So with that I was going to
kind of show you some things
that ADT has done in the
past, which are cool.
So let me share my screen.
So this is before quarantine.
So ADT normally has a breakdown
between showcase and covers.
Our showcases are what I
think we would consider
our like normal ADT, so these
are just like one hour a week,
very low time
commitment practices,
and at the end of the
semester we normally
put on a huge showcase,
normally in [? Lasala. ?]
And it's always like a
very hectic and good time.
And covers are more like
a shorter time duration.
I would say they normally
take four to five weeks.
And during those
four to five weeks,
it's a lot more time
commitment, but the result
is a finished, like very nicely
filmed and edited product
that we put on our
YouTube channel.
So this preview I believe
consists only of covers,
but I will drop the link
to our showcase channel
later in the chat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING - NON ENGLISH
ASIAN SONG]
[MUSIC, NON-ENGLISH ASIAN SONG]
[MUSIC, K/DA, "AIN'T
NOBODY BRINGING US DOWN"]
Ain't nobody bringing
us down down down.
Yeah, so those are a few
snippets of some of our covers.
If you want to
watch them in full,
they're also on the
ADT YouTube channel.
And let's see, Lydia--
Yeah.
Miguel, if you could
show the next video.
I think Lydia said
there was some lag.
There's another one, It's
the Dynamite Challenge,
but I was going to talk a
little bit about it first.
So this is what pre-COVID ADT
looked like, super exciting.
And after-- Oh, hang on.
OK, wait.
I guess I'll answer
the question later.
I guess.
OK.
So basically that's
pre-COVID ADT.
Everything was very
exciting that we always
had a lot of projects going on.
And after COVID
started, we kind of
thought like what we could do
about this whole like distance
situation, because
we're not used to like
not being in the
same room, obviously.
So one thing that we
did for last semester--
obviously we didn't
have a showcase,
because rehearsals
were able to continue,
but we were able to do
a really successful--
I think we had like 200
something attendees.
We had an online premiere of our
showcase videos from fall 2019,
and that was kind
of like a showcase
because it was still
like everyone's together
and we had it on YouTube.
So everyone could like comment
in real time with each other,
and that was really cute.
And this semester we have
a full plan in place,
again with the kind of on
your own time auditions
and then the
asynchronous rehearsals.
And we plan on editing all the
videos together for a showcase,
and we have both editors
within our community.
And we've also reached
out to some people
skilled with video editing
outside of our communities,
who are acting as
like editing advisors
for our choreographers.
So we're planning on doing a
full setlist this semester,
nothing is changing.
And as of yesterday night,
we had around 170 sign-ups,
which is actually
really good, considering
that it's all virtual.
So we're all really
excited for that.
And as part of our audition
kind of promo and pub process,
we put together a fun video
using BTS's "Dynamite,"
which just released.
It's like a huge
deal right now, it's
like number one on pop
charts or something.
So that was a popular
thing that we did.
And Miguel, if you could share
that just so there's no lag.
It's the second link in
the email I sent you.
MUSIC, BTS, "DYNAMITE"
So I'ma going to light it
up like dynamite Whoa oh oh.
So I'ma going to light
it up like dynamite.
Dy na na na, dy na na na, eh.
Dy na na na na.
Light it up, dynamite.
Shining through this city
with a little funk and soul.
Light it up like dynamite.
Whoa oh oh.
We hope you enjoyed
our small surprise,
and now it's your turn to submit
the audition form and join ADT.
So as I'm sure everyone has
heard from other dance teams,
like pubbing is definitely most
important part of this process.
So yeah, as the
pub chair for ADT,
I am proud that we
have so many sign-ups.
We actually made a
bet about it, so I
thought we weren't going we
weren't going to get over 50.
One of our captains
said over 100,
and the last half
of the leg, now
I'm sure that we will
have more than 150.
And I lost the bet, so I have
to buy both of them drinks now.
But yeah, that's all
they have for ADT.
So if there are questions--
Awesome.
Awesome thank you, Joy.
We're going to-- if
you have any questions,
feel free to put
them in the chat.
We're going to have Dan
talk, and then we'll
answer all the
questions in the chat.
Dan.
Hey, hi everybody.
First of all, it's
so amazing to see
all the work the dance teams are
doing that you all are making
and the videos.
It's super inspiring, and
I feel like hard to follow,
so I will do my best, but
we'll see what happens.
I've been-- I'm a lecturer in
movement and dance and theater
arts, and I have been focused
mostly on what I make going,
how do you turn--
I like this idea how do you
turn the scar into a star,
so how do we take the problem
and turn it into an asset.
And looking at how
we can make dance
that is served by this bizarre
video teleconference situation
that we're in, and how we can
make things that are not trying
to approximate what
we would have done
live, but make things that
can only be done with video.
And I've been involved
in a number of projects--
oddly since--
when COVID hit, I was just about
to start rehearsing a show.
I was choreographing a
production at Bard College,
and they immediately
just switched it
to an online production.
So I had one
rehearsal in person,
then everything after
that was virtual.
So I've been getting
a lot of experience
making stuff via Zoom and
how to work asynchronously
and how to make
stuff that will be
effective for a video format.
And then I was really lucky to
work with this choreographer
and filmmaker named Janessa
Clark, who's a New York based
artist, who has this project
called Communion, where she's
getting different people
to film themselves dancing,
and then she's compositing
them into duets.
And there's an artist
named Benoit Lachambre
who's a Montreal based
choreographer and dancer who--
he and I've been like sort
of on each other's radar
for about 15 years, and I've
wanted to work with him.
He's one of my favorite artists.
I've wanted to work
with him forever,
and suddenly with
this situation,
it was an opportunity for
us to make a film together.
So Miguel, if you want
to roll that video
of the duet of
Benoit and I. This
is just a little bit
of a longer piece.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So yeah, you get the idea.
So yeah, with that
project, what we did was we
both worked individually.
I went first filming,
and Janessa set us up
in very specific ways, like we
made parameters that worked.
The camera has a certain
height off the floor
and a certain height
from the back wall,
the back wall had to be white,
so we could match them up.
We both improvised too, either--
we did a bunch.
We both improvised to [? a ?]
[? Bowie ?] [? song or ?]
to Erik Satie, but
then cut the sound out.
And then I went first, then
and while I watched mine,
he kind of made his
a response to mine.
And then actually my
video got messed up,
so I had to make a
response to Benoit.
So we kind of did
like a back and forth
to influence each
other, and then
put all that together and
then sent that-- and then
Janessa sent that off
to a composer, who
wrote brand new music for it.
That was really a process like
layer upon layer upon layer
upon layer upon layer.
And we found that that
was actually a way
that we could work
that would like
was only possible via the
distance and the video
and stuff.
And so I'm looking, I'm
really excited about ways
that we can keep exploring that
rely on the video as opposed
to use it as a hindrance.
Awesome.
Thank you, Dan.
Yes, thank you.
So feel free to continue
adding questions in the chat.
We're going to go with some
very specific ones first,
and then we're going
to go to broader.
So Joy, was the ADT dance team
actually in Downtown Crossing
in Boston?
Yes.
So our covers are
filmed literally all
over the place in
Boston, at AD--
at MIT, sorry, and just like
in the general Boston/Cambridge
area.
We've traveled a long
way for some of them.
So the dance that you
saw, I think was "Miroh,"
I think was actually
in Downtown Crossing
and that was part of our
K-pop in Public series,
where it's like one
take just somewhere.
And we've also entered
some of our covers
in like official big
K-pop dance competitions.
So I remember we had one where
we filmed at four locations.
There was like inside a T
stop in Boston, and Downtown
Crossing, like in
December when there
were Christmas lights at
night, and a few other places,
and they're all
like really cool.
The one you saw that
was on the Charles
River, that was on the dock.
Awesome.
And so also, who does the
styling for your videos?
Who does the styling?
Normally, in the
past we've actually
hired professional video editors
for some of our like bigger
and more time intensive covers.
In the pa-- we've also just had
like specific cover directors
and choreographers
edit their own videos,
but they're all filmed and
edited really well, I think.
Awesome.
And so a great
question was posed that
with the time of being
and [? with ?] everybody
doing on Zoom how do you
manage synchronization issues?
Open to anybody.
I mean, I can jump
on that, and then
I would welcome anybody
to correct me or augment
what I say.
I found that starting
to work and not
being so worried about synced
up is a great way to start.
Just going like, we're
just generating moves,
we're just making stuff, and
we're allowed to get it wrong.
And then when you hit a certain
point of having to sync it up,
at that point I rely
on one person who--
if I'm choreographing, I kind of
pick whoever is like nailing it
and go, OK you record
it and make a video.
And then we're all going
to asynchronously match up
to your moves on this song
and learn it that way.
So at least that way you can--
you're not trying to get
synchronous on a Zoom call,
you're doing it asynchronously.
And then, to be quite
honest, you just
have to hope that there's
like not awful latency issues
if you're performing it live,
or you can do it in the edit
if you're doing it not live.
But it's allowing
for the problems
to be there until you need to
pin it down, has been effective
for me.
And I'd love to hear
other solutions.
Yeah, so I think one thing
I've experienced as well
is like I guess the asynchronous
problem is a problem.
But if one person is
also sharing their audio,
like as if they're playing
the music for everyone else,
then at least for them the audio
and the movement is synced up.
So then you're going to have
like one person sort of lead it
in a way, which allows for
some amount of synchronization.
Yeah, for us
specifically we split up
like sections of the song
we want to choreograph,
and basically like he
took the first 20 seconds,
and then I took the next
20 seconds, and so forth.
And in that way, we were all--
we had our goals in terms
of the section of the
song, and it was easier
to sync up that way.
Right, yeah, and when we were
sort of making our video,
I guess we met up more to
discuss like high level ideas,
like structural ideas and
then we kind of split off
to implement like
specific choreo and so--
Awesome.
Yeah.
In terms of the
synchronization, I would just
add a note like sometimes
if your Wi-Fi is bad,
and you share your
computer video
along with the audio,
that actually makes
the synchronization worse.
So there's actually an option
to share computer audio only,
and that will sync
it up with whoever
is sharing [? this ?] video.
So that works for Zoom calls.
And also when we're
video editing,
and everyone plays
their own music,
there is an option
in the software
we use that actually allows
like automatic synchronization
of the different frames.
So that's really,
really handy, so we
don't have to do it by eye.
Awesome.
We're going to get
to a specific one,
and I'm going to expand
it just a little bit.
So Dan, how was the process
for choreographing the duet
and editing the film like?
And then I also want to hear
from Joy and from Faraaz
and Aniket how you guys
dealt with video editing.
Dan?
For that project I actually
didn't do the edit.
Janessa, whose project
it is, did the edit.
A lot of it was about
scale and make--
because we had the
bodies separately,
we had to make sure the
parameters of filming
were nailed down,
so that like we
actually measured on
the wall and showed
where 6 feet was at one point.
I'm a little taller
than Benoit, so we
like we wanted to get
our actual heights even,
and then you can kind of let
the camera roll from there.
But a lot of it was all
about setup beforehand
and like allowing for as much
variation in the movement
as possible, but in
really strict parameters.
So it's sort of like how do
you troubleshoot it before you
do it, not after the fact.
That, I think, is a
really important aspect
of this kind of making
stuff like this.
And then we both shot way way
way, way, way too much stuff,
so Janessa kind of had
to pick the best chunk
and see how they would fit
together, because she asked us
to shoot maybe 2
minutes, and both of us
gave her about 10
minutes of stuff.
So I think we made
her job harder.
What are you going to do?
It was really-- it
ended up being really
fun to dance around like that.
Joy-- Yeah, I think--
Oh, sorry.
if Joy wants to go before us.
OK, yes.
I think for us, I guess I
mainly edited the video.
So actually we had thought about
doing this concept beforehand
and then I had no video
editing experience.
And so I went and edited
another video instead,
because I wanted to
make sure I knew stuff
before going into this one.
But I guess it was like
the process of finding,
first of all, a
video editor where
I could put in like
multiple screens
and arrange them however I
wanted and stuff like that.
And then after that, it was
just like a lot of googling
to figure out how do I do
this or that [INAUDIBLE]
and bring it all
together basically,
because we had sort
of visually what
we wanted it to look like
already mapped out beforehand.
Joy, you want to jump in on
what ADT does with editing?
Yeah.
So back when we were
doing our covers,
we used to film
many, many times.
So I think we would
normally do nine or 10
takes per cover, just like the
whole dance running through,
which usually would take around
2 hours, 2 to 3 hours just
for filming.
Like filming days
are always big days.
So if you remember the last
video I showed in the Premiere,
we actually did
that during sunset,
so that's why you saw the
sky literally change colors.
And in terms of
editing, again it's
the synchronization
tool on Premier Pro,
definitely like holy
grail of dance editing,
because you're able to
sync different things up
really easily.
And I'm also like
new to video editing.
I just started this summer.
I was making vlogs
for this art program
that was happening also
with the arts office.
So that's kind of how I was
training myself to prepare
for this semester, because
I knew ADT was going
to do a lot of video editing.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So we just have
just a few minutes
left, so I'm going to go with
the broadest question that's
left is, what is the best
setup for virtual dancing?
For example, is it better to
be closer to a computer mic
or better to be far away to get
more of your body in the frame?
I guess I can talk
about this a little bit.
So for me and Faraaz, I guess
it depends on your goal.
So we've been used
to dancing full body
and having your entire
body in the frame,
and like dancing in
a group and all that.
So this is definitely
different, and I
think we kind of went in
with the intention of just,
you know, using
this kind of frame.
So which meant like our face,
upper torso, and arms, I guess.
And so in that case, it
had-- it worked out well,
because we were
closer to the mic
and basically
mimicked a Zoom setup.
Joy or Dan, do you
guys want to chime in?
I think for me what I do is
I actually have a USB mic,
and I use--
it has like almost
a 2-meter long cord,
so what I normally
do is I put my laptop
in the corner of
a room, and then
I move the mic closer
to where I am teaching
or standing or doing whatever.
So my voice and the music,
which comes directly
from the computer,
are both clear,
but you can also
see my whole body.
So that's what
works best for me.
I think if there's a difference
between teaching and making
for teaching.
I've actually gotten--
like the best setup is
a wireless Bluetooth
headset, I think,
so that the sound is coming
through with your music,
so there's not a
discrepancy between the two,
and they're not
fighting each other.
And there's a lot there's a lot
of different schools of thought
and different setups.
And as things get more advanced,
it becomes easier to teach.
But the hardest
part for teaching
is the balance between
you what you're saying
and the music playing
and being in the room.
In terms of virtual dancing,
for making something, I 100%
agree with what Ani was saying.
It's like what is your goal,
and do you want hands, do
with the whole body?
It's the same as like
setting things up on a stage.
And shouldn't someone be in
the center, to the right,
to the left You know, whatever.
There's all sorts
of different stuff.
It's case by case,
completely different.
And there's really
cool stuff you
can do with the virtual stuff.
You can get like
a hand right here,
which is really hard to do
in a proscenium theater.
So you know, there's things
you can discover that make
it even cooler to be on video.
It's just sort of what you want.
Awesome.
We are at time for this panel.
So I want to thank Faraaz,
Ani and Joy, and Dan
for joining us.
And I to thank the audience for
so much wonderful questions.
Feel free, everybody,
to put your--
[MUSIC, WALK THE MOON, "SHUT UP
AND DANCE"]
Oh, we were bound
to get together,
bound to get together.
She took my arm.
I don't know how it happened.
We took the floor, and she said,
Oh, don't you dare look back.
Just keep your eyes on me.
I said, you're holding back.
She said, shut up
and dance with me.
This woman is my destiny.
She said, ooh ooh hoo,
shut up and dance with me.
A backless dress and some
beat up sneaks, my discotheque
Juilet teenage dream.
I felt it in my chest
as she looked at me.
I knew we were bound to be
together, bound to be together.
She took my arm.
I don't know how it happened.
We took the floor and she said,
Oh, don't you dare look back.
Just keep your eyes on me.
I said, you're holding back.
She said, Shut up
and dance with me.
This woman is my destiny.
She said, ooh ooh hoo,
shut up and dance with me.
Oh, come on, girl!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Deep in her eyes, I
think I see a future.
I realize this is
my last chance.
She took my arm.
I don't know how it happened.
We took the floor and she said,
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh, don't you dare look back.
Just keep your eyes on me.
I said, you're holding back.
She said, shut up
and dance with me.
This woman is my destiny.
She said, ooh ooh hoo,
shut up and dance!
Don't you dare look back--